okay so Sony has known something called
the PlayStation portal this is a
portable gaming handheld with an 8-inch
screen and dual sense controllers with
all the same haptics as a normal
controller so you can experience PS5
games anywhere you go and it's only 199
which seems pretty sweet but then the
thing is the more I look into it the
worse it gets first of all it is a
remote player accessory so there's no
local processing happening it's not a
console so PS5 has to be on and
connected to the internet to do all the
work all right fine but worst of all by
far is this thing doesn't have Bluetooth
so the only way to use wireless
headphones officially is to use some
PlayStation link compatible headset like
the new 200 PlayStation pulse Explorer
earbuds that might be the most outwardly
anti-consumer feature in a new Gadget
I've seen in a long time that's like
imagine if the new iPhone comes out and
there's no Bluetooth this year and
there's no headphone jack so in order to
use headphones there's a new Apple
wireless audio protocol that only works
with airpods even for Apple that would
be crazy
Tim don't get any ideas